[Musique]
un lycée de banlieue une professeure
sans autorité et une arme introduites
les apprentis comédiens sont des lycéens
saint quentinois il ajouté vous ou je
tire une création de métier nava jo
j'aimais bien que ça parle de nous
bas-rhin des lycéens on est les premiers
touchés parce qu'on est des élèves et on
est sensible à tout ça au début la pièce
me semblait très compliquée et j'avais
du mal à j'avais du mal et faire ce que
ça a changé beaucoup de ce qu'on avait
vu dans les deux précédents projets et
me fur et à mesure on a appris à
travailler ils sont une trentaine à
avoir répété toute l'année en dehors de
l'entente scolaire un travail
hebdomadaire pour les lycées villeroy et
des cartes
encadrés par la troupe professionnelle
d'un groupe lacasse est forte
c'est par elles parlent de leur
situation et leurs préoccupations
puisque ça se passe dans un lycée il ya
des difficultés avec une prof etc et
puis d'autre part le fait de jouer avec
vilar aussi ça leur a apporté beaucoup
de choses
[Musique]
c'est essentiel on ne peut pas apporter
les mêmes choses
en tant que professeur et en tant que
metteur en scène en tant que comédien
donc chacun apporte sa pierre et c'est
ensemble qu'on construit quelque chose
et quand on est des professeurs
différents dans des lycées différents on
apporte aussi un regard différent sur
les élèves un travail conclu par une
date unique à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt avant pour certains de
réfléchir à la prochaine création
[Musique]